GOOD MORNING OR I'M SORRY GOOD
EVENING.
I WELCOME THE AUGUST WHEN I
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING AYE WE HAVE
FIVE BILLS TO CONSIDER THIS
EVENING.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE ENOUGH
MEMBERS ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW PRESIDENT BLOOM
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE APPEARED QUIRK HERE
REDUCE [inaudible]
IRATE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM [inaudible]
ESTHER LEVINE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME PRESENT
ON YOUR BILL.
WHICH I'M SURE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER SS SECOND BY A DOCTOR
QUIRK.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS BILL IMPLEMENTS
RECENT LA OR COMMENDATIONS FOR A
CLICKING DATE ON CSU ONLINE
PROGRAMS ARE STUCK THE REST
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
OTHERS SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT.
BECAUSE IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
STILL THE ON A DARE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF THIS
BILL IS MINOR NOTES OR WILL COST
TO THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHICH I CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST LEVEL.
AND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
TO CONCUR WITH THE VERY MUCH BUT
IT THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER O'DONNELL.
THE JUDGE PRESENT. FOR WE
JOINING US.
AND THE CONCURRENCE --
YOU ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE MOTION BY MISS REYES AND
A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
GOING TO GO.
OKAY YOU BECAUSE FOR THE MANAGER
MEMBERS AB SEVEN SIXTEEN UPDATES
STATE LAW AS IT RELATES TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SINGLE PLANS FOR
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
IN ORDER TO ALIGN WITH FEDERAL
LAW AND THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AYE ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S COST
IMPLEMENT THE BILL ARE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE AS THE BILL IS
CODIFYING THE DEPARTMENT'S
EXISTING EFFORTS.
THANK YOU TO AYE CLOSE.
THAT'S RIGHT I DON'T THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL CONCURRENCE
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IS IT.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT A
SAID AN EIGHT YOU ROLL CALL.
BECAUSE WE GOT
.
AND YET WE HAVE THE S. B..
NINE THIRTY NINE THE CLAIMS
AGAINST THE STATE --
CALIFORNIA APPROPRIATION ACTION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRISON.
THIS IS OUR CLAIMS WELL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO FINISH.
AS WE ARE ABOUT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO ADDRESS THE BODY AND
SUPPORT.
AND OPPOSITION HERE AND SEE NO
ONE REALLY TO THE CALL UNDERWEAR
AND FINANCE.
OF FINANCES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
ANYONE ELSE THAT I MISSED ANYONE
GOT EVERYONE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS.
SING NINE WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
I KNOW YOU LIKE THE CLOTHES BUT
HELP YEAH.
YOU'RE GOING YOU'RE GOING TO
ROLL IT [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
I'M SO USED TO DATE I'M SO USED
TO THE DIFFERENT COMMITTEE.
A ROLL CALL [inaudible]
DO PASS.
AND SENATOR JACK SOON รณ YOU
ARE HERE WONDERFUL.
SORRY IF THIS ENJOY IS --
THIS IS S. B..
TO TWELVE WE HAVE A MOTION UM BY
MISTRESS A SECOND BY DOCTOR
QUIRK.
ENJOY TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
OF THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ALL ALL
BEBRIEF SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE DOING
OKAY -- THIS
IS A BILL THAT CREATES A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE INDUSTRY
PAID TAKE BACK PROGRAM FOR HOME
GENERATED PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS.
AND MEDICAL SHARPS IT SETS UP A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM UNDER WHICH
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS CAN SAFELY
AND CONVENIENTLY DISPOSE OF
MEDICAL WASTE AND UNUSED MEDICAL
PRODUCTS.
GIVING SOLUTION TO A PROBLEM
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS KNOW TOO
WELL.
MY PRINCIPAL CO AUTHORS.
WE'RE NOT HERE ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
--
WHO WE TOOK --
RECENTLY TOOK AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS FROM STATE
AGENCIES AND STAKEHOLDERS WE
EXPANDED THE DEFINITION OF
COVERED ENTITY TO ENSURE CALORIE
CYCLE HAS FULL AUTHORITY TO
PROPERLY ENFORCE THE BILL.
I COULD ADD ADDITIONAL --
ASPECTS TO IT IF YOU WISH AND
I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
RIGHT SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON SHELTER ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS YOU'RE TO
COUNSEL AND STRONG SUPPORT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU.
ALL ROCK RIGHT CALIFORNIA LIKE
SITES ASSOCIATION WHAT WE DON'T
--
AT WORK HAD AN OPPOSE LISTEN IN
A POSITION WHERE STILL THERE BUT
WE THINK THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
OVER THE LAST SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS
OF SIGNIFICANTLY MOVE THE BILL.
I THIS IS A MUCH BETTER
ALTERNATIVE THAN.
DEPENDING --
WE THINK THIS BILL IS ACKERMAN
SENSES COME A LONG WAY SINCE.
BEGINNING SO I WOULD URGE THE
SUPPORT OF THIS COMMITTEE AND ON
THE FLOOR WHEN HE GETS.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
MEDICARE MEMBERS JUST TO MILAN
ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH DIRECTIVES WE
DO THE MEDICAL WASTE PROGRAM AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND THIS IS
GREAT IT'S A LONG LONG OF IT
YOU.
ALSO FOR ANOTHER TIME HE'LL
DEBATE KEEP THE STUFF OUT OF THE
OCEANS THANK YOU SENATOR.
WE'RE JUST GONNA SAY OUR NAME
WHERE WHO REPRESENTING IN THAT
WE SUPPORT THIS.
NICK OPPOSITE CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY SURFRIDER IN THE REST
OF THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING CARE ROSS ON BEHALF
THE CITY'S A PASADENA STOCKTON
IN THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO ALL IN
SUPPORT.
NICOLE KIDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
JASON RIGHT CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION QUESTION
I THURMOND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MELISSA AM ON BEHALF OF THE
SOLID WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA THE WESTERN PLUS A WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE COUNTIES OF
BICU.
HUMBLE SHASTA AND MENACING OUT
THANK YOU.
IT'S GOOD FEELING RAISE THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION URGING YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY.
SHE ON INSTITUTING THE HALF OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THINK.
THEY CALMLY WITH THE LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MARY PIT ON BEHALF OF THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA.
SUPPORT.
OF QUE DO HAVE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
ACTUALLY I'M SPEAKING CAN COME
UP IF YOU NEED IT OR YOU CAN
SPEAK FROM THEIR RIGHT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION FAR ACCESSIBLE
MEDICINES WHO REPRESENT THAT
GENERICS --
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN HOW WE HAVE
OPPOSITION OF OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED BUT AT THIS LATE DUH
POINT IN THE PROCESS IT'S
OPPOSED.
ON TWO POINTS AND THEY'RE BOTH
RELATED TO THAT.
FISCAL REALITIES OF THE BILL
MEASURE IS ESTABLISHING A BROAD
NEW STATEWIDE.
A PROGRAM FOR TAKE BACKS AND
WE'RE THE ODD PARTICIPANT --
OUT IN THE PROCESS THERE'S NO
DEFINED PROCESS IN THE MEASURE
AS TO HOW.
THE ALLOCATION OF THE COST WILL
BE AND ALLOCATED AND IN OTHER
STATES AND AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
IT'S BEEN ALLOCATED BY VOLUME --
THE GENERICS PROVIDE A 90% OF
THE VOLUME RATHER THAN REVENUE
WHERE WE ONLY CREATE.
A RECEIVE 27% OF THE REVENUE AND
YET WE SAVE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY.
FOR OUR CONSUMERS AND I
HEALTHCARE COSTS AND WE THINK
THAT -- THE
BILL NEEDS TO BROADEN OUR WHO IS
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN SUBJECT.
TO THE FEE --
REIMBURSEMENTS AND THEN ALSO BE
CLEAR AS TO THE ALLOCATION
PROCESS FOR HOW THE FEES TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM --
WILL BE ADMINISTERED ARE FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL.
THANK YEAR ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
A I'M SORRY DIFFICULT DOESN'T
QUESTION --
SO PERHAPS YOU COULD ADDRESS
WHAT THE LAST SPEAKER JUST DATA
SAID.
WELL YES FIRST OF ALL THERE'S NO
FEE LISTED IN THE BILL AND WE'RE
LEAVING IT TO THE INDUSTRY --
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEY WANT TO
GO ABOUT PAYING FOR THIS.
AS GOOD AS A WAY TO GIVE THEM
THEY WANT THAT CREATIVE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
THE BILL WE BASICALLY SAID.
HERE'S WHAT YOU NEED TO DO AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT AND THAT
--
HAS MET WITH APPROVAL OF ALL OF
THEM I WOULD INDICATE TO THAT
THE COST IS AND I KNOW WE HAD
THIS DISCUSSION I HOPE SOMEBODY
GOT YOU THE ANSWER.
IS UP LESS THAN HALF A CENT FOR
EVERY TEN DOLLARS.
HE'S AT THE HALF A CENT FOR
EVERY TEN DOLLARS OF LIST PRICE
OF THE DRUG [inaudible]
IT'S MAINLY.
WE'LL TAKE THAT IS YOUR CLOTHES.
I'VE JUST RESPECT OF THIS THIS A
BILL WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR A
NUMBER YEARS.
UP WE DO THIS OR WE'RE GOING TO
FIND HUNDREDS OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES DOING THEIR OWN TAKE
BACKS WHICH IS GOING TO CREATE
ABSOLUTE HAVOC.
THIS IS A SYSTEM WHERE IT COUNTS
RECYCLES GONNA TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY IT'S GOING TO BE
PAID FOR BY THE INDUSTRY
EVERYONE'S IN AGREEMENT WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF A GROUP THAT'S
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO
COST THEM.
THEY'LL BE AT THE TABLE TO FIGHT
FOR IT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ALRIGHT THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL WITH MR PEROT NOT VOTING
MISTER OBERNOLTE VOTING NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER ACCENT YOU WILL
PROCEED WITH. FOR SIXTY FIVE AS
BEFORE SIXTY FIVE THIS ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
UP MOVE DEVELOPMENT MOTION BY.
DOCTOR QUIRK A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO.
SO TRY TO BE BRIEF ON THIS.
WERE TRYING TO DO WITH OUR
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA MANY OF
US HAVE HAD SIGNIFICANT ADVANCE
IN OUR DISTRICT I HAD THE TOMS
FIRE.
IN MINE WE LOST TWENTY THREE
PEOPLE OF THE FIRES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FIRES CONTINUE TO
BURN WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO TO TRY
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WHILE WE TALK ABOUT THINGS
LIKE THINNING THE FOREST AND
CONTROLLED BURNS SAN.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ONE OF THE
OTHER ITEMS THAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT QUITE A BIT IS
HARDENING OF NOT ONLY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF OUR UTILITY
COMPANIES BUT HARDENING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF OUR HOMES.
AND THAT WE KNOW IS AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT RIGHT NOW WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE ANY RECOURSE TO DOING
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW THINGS
LIKE GETTING RID OF THATCHED
ROOF SO.
I END DOUBLE PAINTING WINDOWS
ARE JUST SIMPLE THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO TO PROTECT OUR HOMES
BETTER FROM THE SITUATIONS AS
THESE HOT AND A WITH THE
EXTRAORDINARY FIRES CHOI
UNITIES.
THE PACE PROGRAM ACTUALLY HAS
SOME MONEY NOW I UNDERSTAND.
A APPARENTLY THERE IS A LOT OF
CONSTERNATION ABOUT THAT PROGRAM
AND AYE I DON'T QUARREL WITH
THAT THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY.
A ATTACHED TO A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
--
AYE WE ARE CARREY'S REFORM BILL.
UP BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE'S MONEY AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE PACE PROGRAM WE ARE GOING TO
ADD THIS OF HARDENING HOMES TO
THE ELEMENTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
OR I SHOULD SAY TO THE MONEY
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE PACE PROGRAM. FOR THIS
HARDENING PROCESS WE'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS THAT LIMIT --
HOW WE CAN BE USED WHERE CAN BE
USED THIS IS KEY TO OUR
PARTICULARLY ARE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT CANNOT
OTHERWISE AFFORD TO DO SOME OF
THIS HARDENING WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO LOSE THEIR HOMES NOBODY?
CAN AFFORD TO LOSE THEIR HOMES
THIS IS ONE ELEMENT IN THIS
BATTLE AGAINST THE CHANGING
CLIMATE THE WILDFIRES THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN THE STATE.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT GOOD
AFTERNOON PAUL MASON PACIFIC
FOREST TRUST --
WHEN OUR BIG CHALLENGES IS THAT
WE HAVE LIKE A MILLION HOMES OUT
IN HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS THAT
WERE BUILT BEFORE MODERN
BUILDING STANDARDS AND ARE
EXTREMELY FLAMMABLE?
WERE NOT ABLE TO SOLVE OUR HOME
LOSS PROBLEM THAT WHEN HOMES ARE
PART OF THE FUEL THIS BILL DOES
A MECHANISM TO MAKE THOSE HOMES
LESS FLAMMABLE MORE DEFENSIBLE
AND REDUCE LOSSES PAINTED IDEA.
THINKING ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
MANAGER MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISSY BELMONT BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING CHRIS ROGERS WITH
BY GREEN ENERGY FINE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING I WOULD ALL
TOMORROW BEHALF OF RENEW IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FILE.
THANK YOU AND NOW THAT IT'S OUT
OF THE ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
THAT CONCLUDES THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
JOURNAL